[MUSIC]
Folks would take a growth mindset,
see the challenges they're
facing as something that they
could develop enough to achieve or
overcome or master or learn from, so
that a failure from a broke mindset
perspective is an opportunity to learn.
One of the thing that goes on when you're
learning from the context of another
people who are different from you,
you are confronted with experiences
that you would never have had.
Now, if you're in a group with
a lot of people who look and
have very different experiences and now
you begin to share those experiences, you
gain from that living knowledge about what
it is like to be a very different person.
And they're saying, well, here's what
happened when we used that approach.
And somebody else who raised
their hands and say, yeah, but
here's what happened when
we used that approach.
And they're so different.
And that's incredibly educational
from a developmental perspective and
make sure begin to realize things that
you have been taking for granted or
possibilities that you've never consider.
I remember hearing a Ukrainian
mass retailer comparing
what was going on in his organization
to an executive from Lululemon.
And the learning that came out
of that interaction was amazing.
That diversity allows you to
start thinking of possibilities.
And remember, it's thinking of
possibilities that makes it possible for
us to engage in the developmental
approach to work.
>> Transform your approach to
leadership excellence and development.
Learn more about SEP,
the Stanford Executive Program.
[MUSIC]